breaking today Arnold Schwarzenegger is
leaving Celebrity Apprentice who
terminated in a statement just released
Arnold was pretty blunt quote everyone
from the celebrities to the crew to the
marketing department was a straight ten
and I would absolutely work with all of
them again on a show that doesn't have
this baggage what Arnold men fight this
baggage is pretty obvious
since he first went on the air in early
January Arnold has faced a barrage of
criticism from the previous host of
Celebrity Apprentice now President
Donald Trump for instance Wow the
ratings are in and Arnold Schwarzenegger
got swamped I want to just pray for
Arnold if we can what ensued was a
virtual war of tweets between the two
from Arnold I hope you'll work for all
of the American people as aggressively
as you worked for your ratings then from
Trump yes Arnold Schwarzenegger did a
really bad job as Governor of California
and even worse on The Apprentice
Celebrity Apprentice ratings are down
since Arnold took over more than three
million viewers for his recent finale
compared to over six million for Trump's
last finale both down heavily from the
first season which averaged 21 million
viewers no comment yet from NBC on
whether the show will be renewed
you